I'm section away on the pass food
feeding Tristan Thompson now you've
started to see the game professionally
now when the season first time he didn't
see the basket and a foul on to rubber
move inside by the young fella it's the
tough pass over the top kept it high
terrific Oh with the proper here's
Johnson with the turnaround that's off
the bar he's not shot the ball well
that's coming back for help Drummond's
back in he's matched up with him
timer waiting on high that's a nice move
I like to see more of right here he just
goes in one dribble uses his length and
his quickness to get over Drummond who's
a very good shot blocker got that shot
over him
Crawford on the drive beats it up big
fella for this leg
[Applause]
he is so good at that pick and roll
great pass they're playing
so even allowed the Grizzlies to be in
this situation we are watching a young
player blossom in front of our eyes a
career-high 34 including 3 of 6 from
downtown talk about ice water in the
vein for the 19 year old building fires
and misses
knocks flooding the floor catches and
throws it down that time the pass on
point from Ottawa doll eyes wide open
previously knocks mr. dally you cute the
3 at 37% tonight their way of either
averaged at 53% 8 of 15 shots
Leonard the big man out of Illinois from
free above the rim Jaron grant setting
him up beautiful at time how about this
drive to the paint and it comes to
Denman John trying to spit boo I broke
that up down prey on the bounce college
somebody got up and in oh that was a
nice flip by John Connors but even a
better fine by Trey young caught a
little bit gets in trouble
Trey young gets in goes straight down
the sideline nice little tricky dribble
over the top for John Kahler with anger
yeah he's tough
[Applause]
those 8 Drummond inside a parking meter
Fayed Carter swats it away give me that
able to do much coming from Duke because
he's been he'd been able to force the
miss to Simmons runs the floor inside it
snaps it down over Simmons
Betty pop that has been dumped it on the
way down in footer you just made it
shattering swing he can check yourself
Simmons Jaron with the knock away
finally looking for a cutter Jaron
presents himself and flips it in Rudi
eight catches goes knocks knocks to the
rim it's Heather Knox with 15 points
whose turn at the basket that in touch
the iron I don't think so shot thought
still running down the tree down to two
dodge it from the front Brooks he was on
the bench it plays just so tough to
guard Luca shot clock and that is that's
[Applause]
can you keep this man down you can't he
hasn't played he comes in the game
though he doesn't give me a high light
took a hand to the face to it it's
wrestling mats underneath shortened to
Chandler
they got tied up blocked by dodges once
twice on his hero LeBron push off and
step out of bounds as we get another
look at a couple of blocks on LeBron
James
he's trying to exploit something to get
to the other team out of what they like
to do
[Applause]
sense of rebound and look at miles
bridges Rudy Gobert look as soon as he
realizes oh oh that's x0 coming at me
I'm not gonna jump at that one I'm just
gonna give it off bridges off with two
feet oh that was a walk in the park four
seconds left for dodging from deep
Lucca notches with about what was that a
40-footer watch it again is da judge
picks up points number 13 14 and 15
Dallas out scores Houston in the second
quarter 38 to 28 tough on fellow Chicago
guy Frank Kaminsky
knowing that you've got a hot guy behind
you good anticipation right there by
bleep to peel away come back for the
spiel and just a quick look and this
will liven up a Sunday afternoon crowd I
mean that is no verbal communication
that's just I contact and knowing that
you've got a hot guy behind you good
anticipation right there if I flick the
peel away come back for the spiel and
just a quick basketball Jordan John
check score right out of the timeout
Mavs back screen there's Dennis Smith
junior just throwing it down easily